hello everyone my name is jason mays i'm
the developer advocate for tensorflow.js
here at google
which basically means that if you're
using machine learning in javascript in
some shape or form out in the wild
there's a good chance we'll cross paths
at some point
now with that today i'm going to talk to
you about using machine learning in
javascript of course so let's get
started
now first up i want to talk about how
machine learning has the potential
to revolutionize every industry not just
for tech ones but all of them
in fact we could be standing right here
at the beginning of a new age
we've already been through the
industrial and scientific revolutions
but what about the future
there could be a machine learning one
too and we could be at the very
beginning of that right now this is a
really exciting time to start learning
about machine learning
as you can jump on the bandwagon early
and really get involved and have impact
of course before i get started on that
what's the difference between
artificial intelligence machine learning
and deep learning i'm sure many of you
today have very different backgrounds
and it's important to understand what
all this is all about and where it comes
from
and what all these key terms mean so we
can understand what we're going to be
making
later on now first off i want to start
with artificial intelligence
also known as ai this is essentially the
science of making things smart
or more formally human intelligence
exhibited by machines
but this is a very broad term in fact
and right now we're actually in a place
of narrow ai this basically means that
the system can do one
or a few things just as well as a human
counterpart could do in that niche area
such as recognizing objects and a great
example of that
is when people in the medical industry
are trying to understand what brain
tumors look like
nowadays experts use machine learning to
actually work alongside them to help
point out
what parts of an image may contain a
brain tumor for example
and this leads to better results because
sometimes it's just too grainy for the
human eye to see
but ml can pick up on these fine
differences which leads to better
results for both the patient and of
course the doctor now machine learning
on the other hand or
ml in short is an approach to achieve
artificial intelligence that we just
spoke about on the previous slide
now the key part about these systems is
that they can be reused
and this is done by creating systems
that can learn to find patterns
in the data presented to them this is at
the implementation level if you will
so if you have an ml system that is
trained to recognize cats
you can use the same system to recognize
dogs
just by giving it different sample
training data so if you just roll back
to traditional programming as you can
see on this slide here
you can see that in the old days we'd
use lots of conditional statements in
order to find spam emails for example if
the email
contains a certain word mark it as spam
now this is not very efficient because
the spammer can just change the word
slightly and get around those
conditional statements now fast forward
to today
and machine learning programs
essentially get tons of emails to
classify
which are marked as spam by you and it
tries to find what
attributes of those emails led to it
being classified as spam all by itself
so now there's no battle between
programmer and spammer and instead
the end user can concentrate on making
great software instead
so what common use cases are there then
well actually there's quite a few
these are the typical use cases i see
machine learning being used for about
others of course but we've got things
like computer vision like the object
detection example we just spoke about
we've got numerical things like
regression predicting a number
natural language for example uh text
toxicity or sentiment analysis
we've got audio for speech commands for
example
and my personal favorite is generative
which is essentially things like style
transfer and the creative kind of
applications of ml
and you can see on this slide an example
from nvidia whereby
they are generating human faces and
these faces do not actually exist in the
real world
it's been trained on celebrities in this
case and you can see how now
this research can actually produce very
cool imagery
so what about deep learning essentially
deep learning is a technique for
implementing machine learning that we
just spoke about on the previous slide
and one such deep learning technique is
known as
deep neural networks so you can think as
deep learning as the algorithm you might
choose to use
in your machine learning program
essentially so if you haven't
heard of deep neural networks don't
worry essentially these are just
programming structures for our arrange
in layers that are
loosely trying to mimic how we believe
the human brain to work essentially
learning
patterns of patterns and we get into
that in more detail later in the talk
so in summary here you can see how all
these terms are actually interlinked
we have the deep learning that feeds
into the machine learning so
the algorithm that goes into the
implementation and that machine learning
gives us this
grand illusion of artificial
intelligence which is what we're trying
to aim for
longer term and these terms actually go
back to the 1960s and 50s
it's not anything new it's just that now
we have the power
with all the cheap processes and memory
uh that we can actually make use of
these techniques at scale
with all the data that we now have this
previously wasn't possible
in the older days so how do we train
machine learning systems and that's a
great question
essentially we need features and
attributes
and you can see here from this example
if you just pretend to be farmers for a
second
trying to classify apples and oranges
two features or attributes you might
want to use would be weight and color
these things are easy to measure
digitally and can be
accessed at scale so once you've got
those if we go back to our high school
maths
we can try and plot those features and
attributes on this 2d graph here and
we've got weight on the y
axis and color on the x and you can see
how the green apples and red apples
kind of clustered together there at the
bottom in their respective color
spectrums
and then the oranges because they're
juicy they're actually slightly higher
up on the weight
uh axes there and we can draw a line to
separate the apples and oranges apart
and in a way this is actually a very
naive form of machine learning
if we could get a computer to figure out
the equation of that line
because if we now classify a new piece
of fruit we take its weight and its
color
and we plot it on this graph if it falls
above the line
we can say with some level of confidence
that that piece of fruit is an orange
and if it falls below the line we can
assume it's probably an
apple and that's kind of what is going
on in all of these systems
the machine learning is essentially just
trying to figure out the best way
to separate the data so that it can
classify it later on
what about bad features and attributes
it's not always obvious what you should
choose here and here
is a great example ripeness and number
of seeds this could lead to a scatter
plot as you see
on the chart right now and there's no
easy way to separate this data with a
straight line or even a curved line for
that matter
and this is a good example of a bad
choice of features and attributes
and you might be like well why jason
would you choose such things and it's
not always as simple
as apples and oranges imagine those
brain tumors we're talking about earlier
on
what features and attributes would you
use to be able to distinguish
a positive from a negative result in
that case it gets very hard very quickly
and this is known as feature engineering
to find the set of features and
attributes that give you the best
separation in data
and that's what folk get paid a lot of
money to figure out properly but what
about higher dimensions
in our simple example we had just two
dimensions let's assume we had three
in that case we'd need to plot it on a
three-dimensional graph as you can see
on the right-hand side
and here we instead of using a line we
need a plane
or a rectangle in 3d space if you will
to
be able to separate the data in a
meaningful way
now it's actually interesting to note
that most machine learning problems are
actually using much higher dimensions
from three
now unfortunately our human brains just
can't comprehend uh what that looks like
but you have to trust me if the math is
actually the same
and instead of using a plane you're
using something called a hyperplane
and that just means it's one dimension
less than the number of dimensions that
you're working with
but the math works out the same and
you're using this high dimensional space
and dividing it up in much the same way
so it should be easy right
we've got a dog we've got a mop what
could possibly go wrong
well some dogs look like mops and vice
versa
and my point for bringing this up is
that you've got to be aware of the bias
in your training data one of the biggest
challenges you'll face
is not finding enough training data that
is unbiased for the situations you want
to use it in
so in the case of recognizing a cat
something as simple as a cat
you might need to have 10 000 images of
cats of different breeds
different stages of a life cycle
different shapes sizes
in different environments different
lighting conditions taken on different
cameras
all this is required to have the best
chance of understanding what cat pixels
actually
are and without that you may end up
having biases in your machine learning
model
which would be very bad the other point
to note here is that data is not always
imagery
it could be tables of data with text
or sensor recordings sound samples and
pretty much anything else you can think
of as long as it can be represented
numerically
we can use it in an ml system so that
brings us of course to javascript
why would you want to do machine
learning in javascript and that is a
great question too
in fact javascript can run pretty much
everywhere in the web browser
on the server side desktop mobile and
even internet of things
and if we dive into each one of those
you can see many of the technologies
that you already know and love
on the left hand side there we have
popular web browsers you might use on
server side we have node.js
for mobile we can support react native
and also other things that wechat and
progressive web apps of course
and for desktop electron can be used to
write native desktop applications
and of course raspberry pi for internet
of things
and javascript is the only language that
can be used across all of these devices
with ease without any extra add-ons and
plug-ins and that is a very unique point
about javascript on its own which i'm
sure you're already aware of
and of course with tensorflow.js you can
run
you can retrain via transfer learning
and you can write
your machine learning models completely
from scratch if you so desire just like
you could do in python
if you're familiar with machine learning
in python
and that allows you to basically dream
up anything you might want
from augmented reality uh gesture
sound recognition conversational ai
whatever it might be
you can do that in javascript now as
well giving you superpowers
in the browser and beyond so there's
three ways you can talk
about using machine learning in
javascript i'm going to go through all
of those now
the first one is pre-trained models
these are essentially really easy to use
javascript classes for common use cases
and you can see we have many of these
already from object detection
body segmentation which allows you to
find where the body is in an image
pose estimation to detect the skeleton
and
we've got speech commands and much much
more in fact some of our newer models on
the right hand side there you can see we
now support face mesh
which can recognize 468 landmarks on the
human face
we've got hand pose that can detect
similar things for your hand
and also the q a model that allows you
to do
question answer based natural language
processing all in the web browser
so let's see some of these in action and
see how they perform
so first up i want to talk about object
recognition this is using coco ssd which
is the name of the machine learning
model that we're
using to power this and that has been
trained on 90
object classes such as these dogs on the
right hand side so 90 common objects can
be recognized out of the box
now what's important is that you can see
that this also gives back the bounding
box data
which allows you to localize it in the
image and that's why we call this object
recognition
instead of image recognition image
recognition is where you know about the
thing exists but you don't know where it
is
so this is a pretty cool one to start
with i'm going to show you how we can
write code
to make this actually work ourselves so
let's dive into the code now
so first up let's look at the html
this is pretty boilerplate stuff we're
simply going to
import a style sheet there style.css and
then in our main body
we're going to have a demo section that
initially is going to be invisible so
you can see class invisible is set
at the very beginning there and then we
have some images that we want to be able
to classify on click
so these all have the class classify and
kick and an image contained within that
containing div now this could be any
images you want
and then at the end there you can see we
simply have three script imports
the first one is essentially bringing in
the tensorflow.js
bundle the second one is bringing in the
coco ssd machine learning model
and the third one is of course the
javascript we're going to write
to get all of this working so looking at
the first lines of the javascript
first of all we're just going to define
a constant called demos
section and that's just going to get a
reference to the demo area
where all of our images are living we're
going to set a variable model has loaded
and set it to false
and also define a variable for the model
to store that once it has loaded next we
need to load the model of course so all
we need to do is call coco ssd.load
and because this is an async function we
use the then method to
call back a anonymous function in this
case with the results
and you can see that anonymous function
simply takes the loaded model as a
parameter
and we can then assign that to our more
global variable uh called model
and we set model has loaded to true so
we know that things are ready to use
finally we remove the invisible class
from our demo section
to make sure it's now visible and not
grayed out like it was before
so next we get a reference to the image
containers i.e all the divs
that had that classified on clip glass
we can then loop through all of those
and
essentially add a click handler to each
so that we can decide what to do when
each image within it is clicked
and here we go here's the handle click
definition we simply check if the model
has loaded
if it hasn't we're going to return
straight away because there's no point
doing anything unless the model is
available to use
and if it is available to use we're
going to essentially call model.detect
and we're going to pass it the image
that was clicked so the event target in
this case
and then again this is an async
operation so we use the then
to then call our other function handle
predictions once it's ready
and in handle predictions you can see we
now pass a predictions object
that simply we can log if we wish to
kind of inspect as we so desire
but essentially this contains all the uh
machine learning predictions that came
back for that single image that we tried
to classify
so we can loop through those predictions
and we can create a new paragraph
element for each
and set what we've what we saw along
with its confidence
and then we can also set the margin of
this paragraph so it sits nicely
at the bottom of the bounding box and
then of course
this thing called highlighter is
essentially the bounding box that i've
created and we're just setting the x y
width and height coordinates of that
element
so that it sits in the right place in
the context of its parent div
and then of course we just add these two
elements to the dom and
that should now be visible and finally
the css
is pretty self-explanatory for various
moments when we're changing vague
so if we put it all together this is
what we get
so as you can see this is the code
running and i can now click
on one of these images and you can see
instantly
i get results coming back with the
bounding boxes showing the items that is
found in each image
i've actually added a little extra bit
of code here to do the same thing but
with the webcam
and if i enable this you can see that i
can now see myself too
and notice how the performance is pretty
cool it's running at a high frames per
second
and all of this is running live in the
web browser which means of course
that your privacy is also preserved
because this data is not being sent to a
server for classification
so the next thing i want to talk about
is face mesh you can see here
how it can recognize 468 unique points
on the human face
and it's just three megabytes in size in
fact many people are starting to use
this in creative ways such as muddy face
which is part of a l'oreal group
who are using it for ar makeup try on as
you can see from the image on the right
this lady is not wearing any makeup on
her lips in fact the lipstick is being
chosen dynamically at runtime
in the browser and then we're applying
it because we know where the lips are
from face mesh
pretty cool but let's see if it's
running for real using my face so i can
explain a little bit more
okay so now you can see my face in the
web browser and as i open and close my
mouth
you can see it reacts really well uh
it's running at high frames per second
but this is just running on the cpu
i can actually switch at the top right
and we can get even better performance
by running on my graphics card
now in addition to doing the machine
learning in real time because javascript
is obviously great at graphics we're
also rendering a 3d point cloud
that we can also tinker with at the same
time as you can see
i can move my face around on the 3d
point cloud too
so you can use this to make pretty much
anything you want so
next up is body segmentation this model
allows you to distinguish 24
unique body areas across multiple bodies
in real time
as you can see from the animation on the
bottom here but you can see how well
that segments
and it even gives you estimation for the
pose of each body too are you where they
think the skeleton is
which can be used to do gesture
recognition or much much more
now models such as body picks can be
used in really delightful ways too
here's two examples that i created in
just a couple of days that allow you to
do some powerful things
on the left hand side you can see how i
remove myself from the webcam in real
time
rendering myself invisible much like a
harry potter cloak or something like
this
and as i get on the bed you can see how
the bed still deforms
even though i'm removed from the cam
feed in real time
now on the right hand side you can see
another demo created that allows me to
measure
my body size in real time and i don't
know about you whenever i'm buying
clothes i never know what size i
am so i made this to help me out to find
my size
for different brands on the websites
that i use and in under 15 seconds
i can get a result back for my chest
measurements my inside leg and all that
kind of fun stuff
in a much more frictionless way and of
course all of this runs in the web
browser
so my privacy is preserved none of these
images are going to a server
and of course all this can give you
superpowers too
what if you combine tensorflow.js with
something like webgl shaders
in that case you can get an effect like
this which is made by one of the guys in
our community in the usa
which can shoot lasers from your mouth
and eyes all in real time
at a battery smooth 60 frames per second
but let's not stop there if we combine
it with web xr a very emerging
web standard you can now even project
people from magazines into your room
in real time too and this guy is using
this on his phone
and then he can walk up to the person
and and kind of meet them in real life
virtually speaking so that's pretty cool
and i thought well if i can do this then
why not go one step further and combine
it with webrtc
to teleport myself in real time and you
can see here how i can project myself
from my bedroom
into another living space it could be
somewhere else in the world to meet my
friends and family
such that i can be closer to them even
when i'm not
and having tried this myself it actually
does feel better than a regular video
call because you can walk up to the
person and move around them and all this
kind of stuff which you just don't get
with a regular video call
now the next way you can use
tensorflow.js is by transfer learning
this is where you retrain existing
models to work with your own data and
this is the next logical step after
using our pre-trained models
to make things more customized to your
needs now if you are a ml expert you can
of course code all this stuff yourself
but i want to show you two ways today on
how to do this in a super simple fashion
now the first one is teachable machine
this is a website created by google
that allows you to retrain data in the
web browser
for very common tasks like recognizing
an object or
speech recognition or pose estimation
for example
and in just a few clicks you can make
your own ml model
so let's try this out right now and see
how easy it is to use
for something like a prototype so here's
teachable machine
we can click on image project to start
and i can click on webcam
and you can see now that i'm just going
to take a few samples of my head in
front of the webcam
and then i'm going to do the same thing
for class 2
and we take a similar number of samples
but this time i'm going to
use this deck of cards
and we've got a similar number of images
as you can see i'm now going to click on
train model
and essentially that means it's
retraining the top layers of the
model that we're using so that we can
classify new data
using things it learnt from before so in
just a few seconds this process will be
complete
and we can now see a live prediction
coming from the webcam
and hopefully we can see that class 1 is
predicted right now
and uh if i put the deck of cards in
front it should now show class two
class one plus two and look how
responsive that is
it's really really fast and um you can
get this great performance in just a
matter of seconds i think it's like 30
seconds we've made a custom machine
learning model so
do try that out in your spare time and
uh you can use this in prototype so you
can simply hit an export model at the
top right there
and you can save the json files that you
need to then load this model on your own
custom website later on
to do something more useful so maybe i
can share a deck of cards
and reveal a youtube video or whatever i
want to do
now the next method i want to show you
is if you want to do something more for
production use case which is more than
just a prototype you might have a lot
more data
and of course in the web browser you're
limited by the ram that you can use
in a single tab in chrome of course so
if you have like gigabytes of data you
can use cloud automl and this allows you
to train custom vision models in the
cloud
which you can then export to
tensorflow.js just like we did before
um so here you can see i've just
uploaded lots of uh
data of flowers in this case lots of
different folders of different types of
flowers
and all you need to do is then specify
if you want to
train for higher accuracy or faster
predictions and of course with machine
learning there's always a trade-off
between these two things
but you can choose which you prefer you
click next and then
after a few hours of training it will
give you the option to
export to tensorflow.js as you see on
this slide
and it's super simple to use this
exported
json file in fact here's the code all on
one slide
all we need to do is include the
tensorflow.js
library at the top here we then include
the automl library as well
and then below this we have a new image
that we have never seen before
this is just a daisy image i found on
the internet and
we can then essentially use this as the
image we want to classify
and then in just three lines of
javascript below we can now
classify the image so the first thing we
do is we wait for the model
to load so we use
tf.automl.loadimageclassification
and we simply pass it a reference to the
model.json file that you would have
downloaded
from cloud automl and that can be hosted
on your cdn or your website
or wherever you so desire because this
is an asynchronous operation we use the
await keyword of course
and then that gets assigned to model
when it's ready we then get a reference
to our daisy image which is the new
image you want to classify in this case
and we then simply use model.classify
and pass it the image
and await the results to come back and
once this is
allocated to the predictions object this
is just simply a json object we can pass
through
and see all the predictions that came
back from the mr model for that single
image
and of course you can call
model.classifier multiple times
once the model has loaded so if you were
to use this with a webcam
you could then of course do that instead
and have it running in real time on
webcam
data and the third way of course to use
centrifuges is to write your own code
from scratch
now this is for the machine learning
experts out there or people who want to
go
more hands on low level and of course
going on that would be too much for a 30
minute presentation today
but there's plenty of tutorials on our
website which i'll share with you later
to get started with this
but today i'm going to go through the
superpowers and performance benefits you
can get
by running in javascript and node for
example
so first up i want to talk about the
different apis we have available
there's two apis the first one is the
layers api which is essentially
like kiras if you're using python in the
past and
that is a high level api that's super
easy to use
now below this we have the ops api which
is much more mathematical and this is
like the original tensorflow stuff if
you will and that allows you to do all
the funky linear algebra and all this
kind of stuff
um so depending which way you want to go
there's two flavors
of tensorflow.js you can use here based
on your experience and capabilities
so you can see how this comes together
essentially we've got our models at the
top there
bases upon the layers api and then that
sits upon the core or ops api
just below that now that can talk to
different
environments such as the client side and
within the client side you might have
different environments as well like
browser
wechat or react native for example and
each one of these environments knows how
to talk to different backends such as
the cpu that's always available
but also other things like webgl if you
want graphics card acceleration on the
front end
or wasm web assembly if you want to have
better cpu performance
and there's a similar story of course
for the back back end on the server side
with node.js and here it's important to
note that we actually have the same
performance as python land so here we're
actually calling the same tensorflow cpu
and gpu bindings that python has
to the c libraries that tensorflow
itself is written in
and that allows us to get the same cuda
acceleration and avx
support for the processor to make sure
things are running as fast as possible
and in fact if for some reason your
machine learning team is still using
python
then of course you can load in save
python models
from the layers api if you if they're
using qrs and you can use the
tensorflow saved model formats via our
ops api
to load that directly into node.js
without conversions you can just take a
saved model
and then use that in node.js now if you
want to use any one of those saved
models on the client side
then you have to use our command line
tensorflow.js converter
and that will convert the model into the
json format we need to run
in the web browser so let's look at
performance then um
here is tensorflow.js versus python
running mobilenet
and these are the inference times how
long it takes to classify
the thing we're looking for in the image
at the top there you can see
running on the graphics card in python
7.98 milliseconds
and in node.js just 8.81 milliseconds
so you know that's within a certain
margin of error anyways and it's pretty
much the same for all intents and
purposes
now where it gets interesting of course
is that if you have a lot of pre and
post processing
which basically a lot of ml models do
because in order for the model to digest
for data
you need to manipulate the original data
into something that is usable in machine
learning lands
then you can actually get further
performance increases in node.js because
of adjusting time compiler of javascript
itself
in fact we've seen with people like
hugging face which are quite famous for
making
natural language processing models that
they've seen a two times performance
boost just by switching to
node.js for their machine learning pre
and post processing
so now if we focus on the client side
for just a second here are
five superpowers you get which are hard
or impossible to achieve
on the server side now the first one is
privacy as i kind of hinted at before
all of these machine learning models are
running in the web browser on the client
machine
that means at no point is any other
sensor data going to a third-party
server for classification and that's
really important in today's world where
privacy is always top of mind
and with tensorflow.js you can get that
for free of course
now link to this is lower latency
because no server is involved when
you're running on the client side
then we don't have that round trip time
from the mobile device let's say
to the server which could be over 100
milliseconds or more in
a bad mobile network connection and of
course
that leads to lower cost if you have a
reasonably popular website
you might be spending tens of thousands
of dollars on graphics cards and
beefy processors to run those machine
learning models
by running on the client side all of
that hardware is no longer needed
and of course you can just execute
directly on the client machine
as you all know interactivity is a big
thing for javascript it's kind of been
designed for that from day one
so we have a much richer ecosystem for
graphics and charting and all that kind
of fun stuff
and the final point reach and scale
which we all know and love
being web developers ourselves um
essentially anyone can click on a link
in the web browser
and have the machine learning loaded for
free versus trying to do this in
other ways on the server side which
would require you to
first of all understand linux and
install linux then you need to install
the
tensorflow stuff and the drivers for
cuda from the nvidia then you need to
install the github repo
and compile it and make sure it runs
with the environment on the server side
so
all of that hassle goes away when you're
running on the client side and that get
that can get you more eyes on your
research in machine learning which could
be very valuable if you're a researcher
for example
maybe that means 10 000 people can try
your model out instead of the
five people in your lab that can maybe
uncover bugs or biases in your model but
you can then fix
before you see prime time now flipping
to the server side for just a second
there's also some benefits there too of
course if you choose to use node.js
so obviously we can use the tensorflow
save model without conversion
as we spoke about we can also run larger
models than we can do on the client side
due to the memory limitations in chrome
per tab
and of course it allows you to write
code in just one language which is of
course javascript
um which needless to say a lot of devs
use javascript
according to the stack overflow survey
of 2019 i believe 67
of people are now using javascript in
some capacity which is pretty cool
and then the performance benefits of
course you can get by getting the
just-in-time compiler boost in node.js
over using machine learning in python
for example
so with that i would like to talk to you
a little bit about the
resources you can use to get started if
you're interested uh if there's
one slide you want to bookmark today let
it be this one
and the next one actually so essentially
here's some tutorials you can use
to get started these are code labs you
can walk through them step by step
and learn as you go these are really
robust ways to learn
some of the things with tensorflow.js
and machine learning principles in
general
and then of course this slide has pretty
much everything else on the slide
here's our website to get started the
models that you've seen in this
demonstration and many more are
available on our github there
and we have a google group to answer any
more technical questions that you may
have
or maybe thinking about later on and
then finally we have codepen and glitch
which have boilerplate code you can use
to get started
now on the right hand side is our
recommended reading material this is a
great book
that covers everything even if you have
no machine learning background
at all that's completely fine as long as
you know some basic javascripts
this book will take you through
everything you need to know to get your
machine learning chops up to scratch
and with that please come join our
community in fact here's just a few more
examples of what people have been making
just the last few weeks and this is
growing every week
if you check out the made with tfgs
hashtag on twitter or linkedin
you can find what people are making
right now and please do contribute your
own
for a chance to be featured at future
show and tell sessions or even
conferences
and such in the future so the final
thing i want to leave you with is this
last demo from a guy
in tokyo japan uh he is actually a uh
kind of dancer and he's now used machine
learning tensorflow.js to make his
next hip hop video as you can see here
and it's really great to see
creative folks starting to embrace
machine learning as well it's no longer
just for the one percent of people with
phds
um it's now for everyone and hopefully
tensorflow.js can make this
even more accessible to all in the
future and i'm really excited to see
what you will make
and please do tag us with made with tfjs
if you do make anything in the future
so we can share it with the team so that
please do stay in touch
i'm happy to answer your questions after
the talk uh or
connect with me on linkedin or twitter
and
happy to ask questions over there as
well thank you very much for watching
and see you next time